[Music]
hey is the matinee show and look Tom's
back this time yeah I'm excited to do it
myself last time that wouldn't feel that
good yeah you weren't that's alright you
had to get ready for a storm right yeah
we had a deal the storm prep which
didn't even like end up really hitting
us it's like all we got was a little bit
of wind and rain and that was it I mean
that's good it's weather control man
weather weather control technology okay
they bombarded it with those damn
microwaves and moved it yeah they've
been able to do it forever
we'll see well I get well what at Cape
Hatteras dude alike [ __ ] with people
then because they got hit today I think
it may be falling it okay fatter I think
maybe they can only they can only make
it do what they can do just Florida this
is like yeah yeah everybody's blowing
over HAARP yeah we're the control or
aliens but yeah so alright so what we
did this week so we actually did that
our theater was actually closed two days
this week because they thought the
hurricane was coming so we thought we
weren't gonna be able to watch any
theater movies again but then they
reopened yesterday so we actually did
get to see two movies in the theaters
week and we actually watched one on
Netflix earlier this week now we're
gonna do the one we've watched on
Netflix first now this one I'm kind of
running out of like 2019 horror movies
that are on Netflix or shudder or
whatever so I've kind of gone more into
like the thriller direction so the one
we watched today came out in July of
2019 and it was called secret obsession
yeah it's pretty good now I'm gonna say
right off the jump that this is
basically like a slightly higher budget
Lifetime movie that's essentially
exactly what it is
um the acting is better you know the UM
you know the cinematography is a bit
better but it is very much like a
Lifetime movie now if you know that
going into it then you will probably
enjoy just fine it seems to have gotten
like pretty good reviews if you're into
this kind of thing one thing that a lot
of people bitched about and I went back
and watched it like to make sure like
after I watch the movie people are like
if you watch the trailer of it because
you know like on Netflix and they show
you the little trailer it gives away
everything pretty much so it was like
you you will not be shocked to discover
I also wish they had named it some
a bit more wood with a bit more oomph I
mean secret obsession that really does
sound like a Lifetime movie which I
guess is what it is so I guess they knew
what they were doing it's just a very
generic title and it's a kind of in a
way it's kind of generic movies it is
yeah it's a movie of a genre you pretty
much know what's happening and that's
what I mean so that's why I'm not
terribly afraid about like spoiling it
because like I say okay if you've seen
the trailer then it's already spoiled
there's no big twist there's no big
surprise there's nothing like that Jake
gets into a car accident yeah she gets
hit by cars eating right yeah she guess
she doesn't have any memory her husband
is at the hospital trying to pick her up
take her back home and one thing leads
to another that's real life this woman
realizes that this guy picked her up at
the hospital isn't her husband yeah the
husband's stealing him this guy's
stealing this woman yeah yeah I mean and
he's pre-planned it yeah it's pretty
it's pretty cool pretty cool movie I
mean you know all they're trying to take
that the husband's place yeah well
that's exactly what he's doing
even to the extent of basically
photoshopping like [ __ ] and wedding
pictures and family photos like a whole
[ __ ] book of a man because she finds
it like later on he tells her she has a
different name he takes her to this like
admittedly really nice house I'm not
sure if I'd ask too many questions
either somebody they didn't really
explain like we're yeah but there's a
lot now I'm gonna say that much like in
a lot of these kind of Lifetime movies
and stuff there's a really lot of plot
holes and it's like if you think about
it too hard just like well how did that
happen and who's though and you know
what's something that I thought about
later on cuz I did think about this
movie later on I was trying to figure it
out there was one guy that turned up at
the hospital like the kind of the
dark-haired guy with the beard and he
brought her flowers and said he was a
concerned party or so who the [ __ ] was
that guy they never tell you who that
guy was
it's kind of like that movie you saw it
was one about the the white guy who
sells his house to the black couple but
he doesn't actually leave he's still
there
oh the intruder the 'true Durr yeah and
he starts like the scam and all this is
very much like that it's a movie Colin
this one's not as batshit this one is I
mean because that one was pretty bad I
like that one actually better I did -
yeah well because that one's Gary ass
[ __ ] dude like that one as crazy as
it wasn't it's like over the top and it
was just like this ridiculous but it
leaned into ridiculous and I think
that's good um this one like I said it's
it's by all means it's a totally
enjoyable movie it's just it's nothing
you haven't seen before you will guess
where it's going to go that's awesome
and I would have renamed that first one
for like a white man could white man
gonna take your woman white man gonna
take your woman white yellow white man
gonna take your mama
and that [ __ ] would have been even a
bigger hit with Dennis Quaid yeah right
man but because I'm a tenant I'll okay
yeah so as I said this one it's like if
you know what you're getting it's if you
like those Lifetime movies this is like
a slightly higher end version of a
lifetime movie it's not gonna surprise
you there's no twist or anything like
that like they tell you right from the
trailer that the dude that Pixar up from
the hospital she has amnesia and stuff
that's not her husband so you know
there's some bad [ __ ] going on you
pretty much oh we forgot to mention that
the detective in this is played by the
Allstate Insurance guy yeah that's right
he was also a train just sent me some
insurance he was also on 24 though like
he played the president on 24 so uh but
I but I've never I don't watch 24 so
it's like for him he's always gonna be
like the Allstate Insurance out it's
already famous sales because he was in
like a bunch of other [ __ ] too but it's
like so ever because we were drinking we
were watching this so like every time he
turned up on scene to like question a
character or something like that you're
like he's good at is he gonna sell
insurance as like this whole thing that
we did but I mean as generic as this
movie is it's actually a pretty good
example of its genre it's not shocking
or crazy or anything like that but it
was a fun movie I mean we had fun
watching and of course we were a little
bit of Newbery I did why
as usual you know nothing spectacular
but perfectly enjoyable movie it was a
movie and and like I said just don't
think about all the dumb plot holes like
how's this guy getting away with all
these murders how's this nothing else I
just don't think about it it's just turn
your brain off and drink and watch it
and make all stages white man steals
Asian woman persuasion steals Asian
woman yeah pretty much yeah yeah
so yeah it's on Netflix now so if you're
into that kind of thing then you might
want to check it out
you
all right now the second movie we saw
this week I don't want to see this one
for a long time so so a trailer like a
long time ago
this was ready or not yeah good movie
decent movie this was actually really
good like I really liked the look of the
trailer like because I really liked
game-type horror movies like you know
would you rather and stuff like that
which this is kind of along those lines
had a little bit of clue going on in
there there's a lot more to it but
there's a lot more to it than that the
trailer doesn't quite give it away this
is spoiler free right um more or less if
we get into spoilers all say spoilers
this yeah you can skip over yeah there
you know it's about a family that let's
just say one of their ancestors made a
certain kind of but arrangement was kind
of semi paranormal and you know you're
not quite sure if this is some kind of
superstition or what but when Sonny
marries into the family they got to play
this game in order to pass the test yeah
and the game depends on what card is
drawn and as a family that's made a
fortune off the gaming industry yeah
board games and oh yeah they also own
sports teams yeah you know and well this
guy's marrying this new woman and that
and most of the family doesn't seem to
like her I guess because she's too good
hearted really the family these people
are like mega rich do and they're all
horrible very much sweet and she draws
like one of the worst cards possible
which is a fevers yeah which is a high
deceit game and they had to find her by
midnight or by done by dawn and kill her
yeah okay her only way she could win is
survive it yeah but if she survives it
the family believes they're gonna be
wiped out yeah okay so it's a do or die
yeah so she has to she has to death and
that's just a very beginning of the
movie all right it's the first few
minutes so not really spoiling much
there no because I think that a lot of
that was set up in the trailer so if you
saw the trailer I mean yeah essentially
that's that's pretty much the the pitch
it's just this woman's marrying into
this hugely rich family she draws the
hide-and-seek card because it's a
tradition in this family that they have
to play a game on the when one of the
members gets married and she draws now I
actually like because when I saw the
trailer I was thinking we'll wait a
minute why would anybody marry anybody
and bring them to the family knowing
that you would have to that your spouse
would be hunted down yeah well but they
did address that yeah the card game had
so many other options and really that
that card had only been drawn a couple
times and this yeah and they and
actually they have like a like a
prologue that shows that the last time
the hide-and-seek card was drawn was 30
years prior yes so other than that like
everyone that had married up and like in
the past 30 years they had played
completely innocuous games
yeah which evidently they weren't so
horrible they weren't that bad evidently
yeah but you know as things unfold you
know you find out that you know the
families well I guess you could say the
family is a bunch of Satanists yeah it's
kind of like if you like that old
classic movie what was it called
um the legacy yeah kind of reminded me
of the legacy but it's a very different
yeah Adams of but that similar process
similar kana yeah it's like a geeky old
mansion with like a really scary yeah
there's Gary family that has a scary had
a [ __ ] bad history it [ __ ] but yeah
it was a good movie I liked the tone
because it did have humor in it this was
a straight-up horror comedy I mean it's
a comedy right but it's a very very very
dark comedy yeah and I think that if it
didn't have the humor in it what a
Comicon office kind of unbelievable
kinda too corny taking itself a little
too seriously I think I think the humor
was a good touch it was actually I think
this was the best way to approach this
um it is I'm not going to say it is oh
it is a horror movie it's very gory
there's a lot of violence in it um but
the humor in it I think is really well
done it is it is definitely a very dark
comedy yeah and I think the best part
about it and I think a lot of other
reviews that I've read of its subsequent
have been saying this is the lead Samara
weaving now she was also in the
babysitter which if you have Netflix go
watch that [ __ ] right now because that
was a really really awesome movie she
played I think Vesper - no that's that's
a totally different in double-oh-seven
yeah that's a totally totally oka the
kind of look like err
no this um actually a lot of people are
saying Samara weaving looks like Margot
Robbie who played Sharon Tate and what's
fun time which they do look a lot of
like Samara weaving is actually
Australian and she is the niece I
believe of Hugo Weaving obviously very
famous he was in the matrix and all that
other kind of stuff um so she hasn't
been in that mini movie she was in the
babysitter like I said which I think
it's still on Netflix and it's really
really good I really recommend it it's a
horror movie she was also in mayhem
which i think is on shudder or it was
that has Glenn from Walking Dead that
news I haven't got around to watching
that one yet but I've heard that was
pretty good too but I really do think
that she makes this movie because even
like from the very beginning I mean
she's a beautiful woman but the way that
she kind of plays with she she just
seems like a real genuine person and
she's so likable that even from the you
know the very first part of the movie
you're just like you're rootin for you
know what I mean because she's got kind
of this like no [ __ ] kind of
attitude and I like that she has to like
display a lot of range like you know for
this because she's obviously she doesn't
know what's going on at first she thinks
everything is just an eye oh we're just
playing hide and seek whatever and then
you know as the tension mounts up if she
starts to figure out like what the hell
is going on and she has to get like more
and more resourceful in order to kind of
like fight back against them and survive
the night and everything and I in a way
I kind of liked the fact because I feel
like the poster where she's you know
wearing the wedding dress and she has
like the the bandolier or what for
whatever thing with all of the book and
with all the bullets in it and whatnot
um I think that makes it seem like a
little too much like a revenge flick
which I don't really think it is it's
more like a survival horror but also
very funny and so I really really like
that she really kind of sold
and like some of her [ __ ] reactions
were so [ __ ] great yeah um you know
just like I'm not gonna spoil it but
like at the end there's there's a couple
parts at the end we're like she sees
something and she's just like [ __ ] it's
like this diddle under reaction and it's
like really really a Larry try to
imagine the movie without the humor and
I think it just would have been a drag
without the humor I think it'd have been
kind of boring the humor actually made
it I think well yeah like I said and
this is you know first and foremost is a
comedy but it's a dark comedy it's a
satire um I really liked the mansion
where it was shot that was like really
cool-looking and it was like kind of
shot in this dark like candle lit
looking thing so I really like the whole
like aesthetic experience of it and a
lot of the actors were really good the
guy that played the the one brother like
the drunk brother I think his name's
Adam Brody the actor he was great in it
too because he was kind of like a wild
card and you never knew like which way
he was gonna because not everybody in
the family was like totally on board
with this killing thing because like I
said it didn't happen every year it just
happened every once in a while so there
was some of that like morale going on
I'm not really sure if they have to do
it right that's it yeah and that's
another thing too so there was like a
little bit of ambiguity so I mean if you
like horror comedies if you like game
type movies you know kind of like like
would you rather or truth or dare or
even though I didn't really like truth
or dare all that much I did like would
you rather and it also has kind of a
clue thing going on with like the humor
and like the murder mystery type aspect
but I I really really loved this movie
and I feel like it's funny because a lot
of the other reviews that I've been
reading of it were like well this one
kind of came out of nowhere for me it
didn't because you know we go to the
movies all the time so I had seen the
trailer like several times but I guess a
lot of other horror fans that don't go
to the theater that much they hadn't
really seen the trailers they're like
wow this one came out of nowhere and
like we went to see it and we just
thought it was great so it just kind of
like snuck up on us and everything so I
mean this is definitely definitely one
of the best movies we've seen this year
was the point yes where are the better
horror movies this year oh definitely
and like I said the humor and it was so
funny I especially liked that [ __ ]
the woman that played
hélène you just like that scary woman if
like the [ __ ] hair it's like
somebody's atonally it kind of reminded
me not quite like it with witches of
eastwick I mean that's kind of an old
movie yeah I don't know I was kind of
like what kind of like a legacy but a
little a little bit but more humor in it
yeah but it just some about it it
reminded me a little bit of Tim Burton's
dark shadows except a good okay yeah
because I didn't like Tim Burton's dark
shadows but it kind of looked like that
like in the way that but I mean it was
cool because like every member of the
family like had their own personality
quirks and they were always kind of
funny to watch almost kind of like a
more violent version of like maybe The
Addams Family yeah they did come off as
kind of Addams Family ask not quite so
gothic but you know what I made it was
that kind of thing yeah they weren't
cartoon characters but it was kind of
had that I don't know it wasn't like
some kind of earth-shattering movie or
anything it's nothing there was nothing
brand-new
it was just a decent horror movie this
year yeah it is like I said I had a
blast with it I thought it was hilarious
like one scene in particular I'm
probably not gonna spoil that either but
like one scene that involves punching
someone that like made me laugh out loud
for some reason yeah but yeah I had a
lot of fun with this movie if you like
horror comedies if you you know if
anything I've said like makes you want
to see it I've seen it compared to like
clue mixed with the purge which I guess
is kind of similar to so if that sounds
like something that would be up your
alley then by all means check it out go
see it because like I said it seems like
a really small movie it's doing better
than they expected but you know kind of
a little indie movies from Fox
Searchlight so
right and the third movie we saw this
week was one again we've been looking
forward to it for a very long time it
was it Chapter two it's a must-see movie
it really is I mean we really really
loved the first chapter so we've been
waiting for this for what like two
[ __ ] years yeah yeah I'm glad I'm
glad that you know that they made it as
as far as like a - you know like a -
movie series or a multiple movie series
in the horror genre this is this is the
best one yeah
is this you know something we're saying
that this that the second entry is not
quite as good as the first one I don't
really agree with that I think it's as
good as the first one it's different
than the first one but that's what it
wasn't a book yeah I mean you're gonna
have to approach it a different way like
I will say I don't think it was as scary
as the first one but also cool though
but yeah but also I think that that is
to be expected because I mean the first
one is almost entirely from the kids
point of view and obviously [ __ ] is much
scarier when you're a little kid you
know and things become less scary when
you're an adult since this is mostly
centered on the adult characters then
yeah I think it's not gonna be quite as
scary this but in some ways - and keep
in mind that I haven't seen the first
one since it came out in the theater so
it's been a while since I've seen it but
to me the tones seem very similar yeah I
mean I thought got it by on both on
blu-ray gotta have both yeah I really
would like to see them both like in one
sitting so I can like remember what's I
mean I remember a lot from the first one
but in the second one you know they have
to come back to Derry and they're coming
back as adults to deal with you know the
clown they eat clown I wasn't named
pain-wise yeah and there's also some
flashbacks of them as kids some stuff
that you know really wasn't addressed in
the first yeah movie you know I mean and
really pretty much everything comes
straight out of the book as far as I
remember I mean that's pretty much how I
haven't written in a long time and
that's pretty much how I remembered the
story going yeah it's uh it's a long
movie it's three hours long almost three
hours yeah
and that's a long time to sit there it's
still good
ain't no I mean I had a good time
through the whole movie there was some
parts where I thought they spent a
little too much time on the character
development I think that could have been
slightly shortened you don't I mean the
scene wise but I think maybe not you
know no I mean Who am I to say because
it's really hard to execute a book in
movie it really is it's it's a very
difficult process so basically you just
make it a big series of choices how are
you gonna do this yeah what are you
gonna leave in yeah and take out when
you gotta focus on it and I'm just gonna
say they they did a good job they did a
good job it's a good movie I think they
did as well and I have to say really
that every single person that they cast
as the adult version of the kids was
perfect
yeah you could actually believe I
actually forgot that they were two
people you know what I mean it's like
yeah I know who some of that's like I
know who James McAvoy is yes I know who
defend the wolf artists and stuff like
that but when you're watching it you
could forget that the that's not
actually the kid version of that person
because they did such a good job not
just in the look but the way that they
acted you know what I mean like you
could totally believe they took like the
character traits of each kid from the
first movie and like made like an adult
sized version of it not you know not of
not to the sense where it's like the
dude that you know the grown-up people
are acting like the kids necessarily but
you can tell that the personality of the
kid has like you know is coming through
like as an adult you know what I mean
yeah what another thing that I liked
about it is just that the special
effects were pretty damn good in this
one too yeah and they got into they got
into the exploring what it is that this
monster is yeah where'd it come from you
know and there's good she's gonna close
to the book I want to spoil it yeah yeah
yeah and this is how I always kind of
pictured this monster from the book you
know we know the one the other series
that had what's his name Jim Carrey and
it's him curry in it that was okay but
didn't quite
to adjust this one is closer the way I
kind of imagined yeah about what this
you know especially this at the end the
spider series you know and there's like
you said I think there is some things
missing from it in terms of dairy itself
had kind of been poisoned by this evil
creature yeah and they didn't really get
into that too much yeah that was kind of
a big I mean that was kind of a big
aspect of the book I haven't read the
book in many years but um you know I've
been reading like more summaries of it
just so I could like refresh my memory
and stuff yeah I do think the end of the
book
well the into the book they go more and
he goes more into you know not just the
idea of it as this kind of
transdimensional or whatever creature
that he is like a basically kind of like
an alien yeah that like that feeds on
fear or whatever and like you know works
in these twenty seven-year cycles but I
think that was also a mean in aspect of
the book where this being had been
underneath the town for so long that it
essentially poisoned the groundwater or
poisoned the soil so it made it wasn't
necessarily like possessing the people
of Derry but it influenced him but it
influenced them like to kind of be their
worst selves I think that I mean it was
feeding off that damn town for for a
long long yeah for over generations like
all the fear negative emotion and stuff
like that so it's almost like that was
kind of sort of hinted at in the movie I
think particularly the opening scene
which they took directly from the book
you know Adrian Mellon and his boyfriend
at the fair and they get a you know beat
up and everything that was taken right
from the book so I think you could kind
of get a hint of it there that it's like
that's where all this like that's why
all these people in Derry were so shitty
and hateful and everything like that it
was because of this thing being
underneath there and that was why there
was always like this rot and like the
center of this town but I think I would
have liked to see a little bit more of
that in the movie but like I said you
can see it or not if it's there if
you've read the book like you probably
pick up on it more than somebody that
hadn't read the book but you know it's
kind of like a I don't know it's I guess
it's like a nebulous concept and maybe
that's harder to put on screen
but they did keep the basic theme of the
book and the meaning of the book and you
know the meaning of this store is don't
give in to fear yeah that a small fear
can become a very big fear then end up
becoming a danger so don't focus on on
your own fears and where your fears come
from because that is the basically
that's the only way to defeat this
monster is not to have any fear of it
that's you know yes and that's exactly
and and I think that was good in the in
the book too and it that does really
come come through a lot in the movie is
that you know these things that
frightens you as a kid and then
sometimes they can like metastasize and
then you know when you're an adult
they're still effective they're still
affecting you like it's it resonates
like throughout the years and I think
they were really good at like putting
that across movie yeah in the movie in
order to get the strength that they
needed to defeat this thing each kid had
had to kind of face and overcome their
own demons yeah because they all kind of
go off on their run little we're
diffused kind of like the root causes of
all the fears that they have the
personality faults that they had come
from basically childhood experiences
when you're real impressionable so you
had to kind of purge those out first
yeah and then you'd have a strength to
go up against something like this and
not be afraid of it yeah that's exactly
what I see and it was the whole thing
about you know um you know like Eddie's
character kind of getting over his like
germaphobe ear it is like anxiety about
everything you know Bev's character who
had you know she had an abusive father
and sexually abused her and stuff like
that and then later on when she's an
adult like ends up with a guy just like
that you know even though he has a lot
of money and stuff and so so you're
trying you're you're seeing like the way
that their fears as children like
manifested themselves as adults
yeah and how they had to go back and
like get rid of that worst part of
themselves yeah in the movie is saying
that you know I mean it doesn't matter
about your your moral judgments on
situations you have to let go of things
yeah you know I mean because sometimes
grab a lot of these things will make it
worse so some of it you just
leave it in the past so you can come you
could confront the present and in guys
if they had to deal with this damn
monster yeah this monster would prey on
you by using you know you know the the
childhood trauma the fears and [ __ ] that
you're carrying with you
yeah that's your Achilles heel yeah I
mean it's it's you know it's an allegory
yeah an allegory for adulthood and I
think yeah and I think that came across
really well now I have to say probably
like I said all the actors in it were
great they all seemed very much like
their kid counterparts I love James
McAvoy and pretty much anything so he
was awesome in this also the guy that
played Ritchie Bill Hader he's in a
whole bunch of other stuff too but a lot
of reviews I read said he [ __ ] stole
this movie and he kind of did in the
book he was a radio DJ I think in this
they made him a stand-up comedian but it
was like a similar it was a similar vibe
so this movie is actually you know
speaking of stand-up comedians this
movie is actually much funnier than I
was expecting
although I guess when I thought about it
I was like you know I guess the first
one was funny too
because they especially like all the
smack talk between like all the colors
in show was the book it was yeah yeah
there was a lot of good callbacks and
easter eggs callback - alien callbacks
to the shining yeah you actually heard
it was his name missed you heard mr.
Torrance yelling uh uh here's Johnny and
stuff at certain times so you know that
in this universe The Shining also
happened yeah you know as weird stuff
that also a nice little shout out to the
thing yes I said no you said the shining
of the shine before that you said I did
you said something else he said alien
alien no there might have been no there
was something front from the alien
there's the face there's a face hugger
shout out and this then there's also a
thing shout out with the that one was
the most obvious it really it made us
both bust up laughs you'll know when you
see it obviously if you've seen the
thing but yeah so this um okay so I
don't know like I said I don't think
it's as scary it's more focus
on the characters which I guess the
first one was too you know so I don't
know I said it's probably one of my
favorite scenes in it I think wasn't
even one of the scarier scenes I did
like a lot of the penny wise scenes
because with him like you know Killa cuz
he does like kill kids in this so yeah
you do too floating through the air with
the balloons the laughs and he didn't
quite have as much dialogue as I think
he wasn't in it quite as nice man and as
much for I mean he was in it a lot but
he was in it but he was in it taking the
forms of other things and other people a
lot yeah yeah yeah I mean that's another
thing is that you find out that whatever
its form is it has to it has to abide by
the rules of the form whatever you are
said it then and then the only way you
know you have to get this thing to start
showing its true form and you know yet
almost boil it yeah part of thing is
just do they try to get this thing two
tickets to what its true form is yeah
what true form is you'll see you'll see
well yeah it does have a true form yeah
yeah and I think it's different than the
book although it's been a long time
since I've read the book so I don't
remember yeah I don't really remember
yeah there was some so I remembered that
they left out of the book and I actually
I'm kind of glad that they did you know
that they changed a few things from the
book and in those senses I'm glad they
did but like I said I'm not gonna spoil
it but one of my favorite scenes was
actually not really a horrific scene it
was when you know all the remaining
losers come back to Derry at the behest
of Mike Hamlin who is the only guy that
stayed in town like everyone else moved
away and forgot so they all come back
and like have kind of a get-together at
this Chinese restaurant you know where
they're all like reacquainting
themselves and the character interaction
between all of them is there like
remembering like you know [ __ ] that
happened to them as kids because like I
said they had all forgotten about it
they had all forgotten about each other
like when Mike calls each one they're
like Mike who who are you I don't
remember
so just the fact of them getting
reacquainted remembering things and
stuff and they're just like talking [ __ ]
to each other it just seemed so it was
so natural and like so organic and like
I said that was another thing that's a
testament to like the really good acting
in this is you could totally buy that
these people all knew each other's kids
and they were getting back together and
they were falling back into those
patterns again of like the friendships
that they had had back then so I really
really liked those kind of little
character moments like that I remembered
the first it at part one being a little
more intense yeah like I said the first
one was scary right the second one
though I think it was still kind of a
masterpiece it was it had a lot of story
content in it yeah they liked the first
one the second one doesn't let you down
I wasn't yeah and like I said now that
I'm thinking about it the themes were
very similar and I guess I shouldn't
have been surprised by how funny this
one was yeah because I remembered when I
was thinking back that I'm like yeah the
first one was kind of funny too like I
said like and it had like a lot of the
same like character interactions because
it was making you care about the kids
and I think this one was also very
successful in getting you to care about
these people as adults and there is some
stuff with them you know flashbacks with
them for the kids and stuff like that
and I didn't really realize it cuz I
didn't notice when I was watching it but
they had a DA j-- you know the kids
particularly Finn well part because if
you watch stranger things he looks
completely different but he did cuz he's
like grown up a lot so they had a DA a
lot of the characters to make them look
the same as they did in the first movie
because it's been a couple of years
since they shot it I didn't really
notice that a lot of the monsters you
know are CGI clearly but you know that's
it didn't Bob didn't matter because the
stuffs a lot of it's happening and kind
of like induced dream sequences and
stuff that this thing can make you
hallucinate while you're awake yeah so
it's like what you're seeing isn't
necessarily really there so yeah so it
gets a pass and that's cool honestly one
and one of my favorite scenes - and I'm
almost kind of like bummed out that they
kind of spoiled it because they made it
the trailer was when Bev goes to her old
apartment
and meets that weird old lady yeah I
wish they wouldn't spoil I wish they
like that was a great trailer but it's
like when it came in the movie I'm like
oh man I wish I didn't know what was
gonna happen because it's like because
it's such a great scene and I think that
was honestly one of the best you know it
in the middle part of the movie where
they all have to go off on their own
personal journeys and like battle their
own personal demons or whatever
I think hers was probably the best one
so I kind of wish they hadn't made that
whole thing the trailer I mean that was
parts in it that weren't in the trailer
too like they you know obviously they
cut it short but you know and you did
get to see at the end like what happened
at the end like where the trailer like
just cut it off so that was pretty cool
but you know I do kind of I was kind of
wishing that like when I was watching
that scene because I really really do
like that saying a lot because that like
these creepiest [ __ ] finale was quite
cool you know them fighting
Pennywise yeah and the things that they
could do the different forms they could
take I liked it and I was like and you
know Testament again to the actors it's
like I was actually kind of cheered up
at the end it was kind of sad I think I
think I cried even in emotion I I cried
at that at the ponytail I cried at that
in the book too yeah I saw you know I
didn't cry at that at the movie but I
was just like you know what I mean but
you know if you've read the book like
you know that I think it's pretty sad
but uh yeah so as I said it's been a
long time since I've read the book so I
can't I remember some things that were
in the book that weren't in the movie
and vice-versa so you know when I
remember that was pretty close it was
very close and like I said I think this
was a lot more faithful to the book then
even the first I mean the first one is
pretty faithful to the book or at least
the spirit of the book this one a lot of
the plot points were exactly the same
like the first chapter here's chapter
okay
yeah this one stuck to the book more
closely like I said even that the
opening scene like with the fair and
Adrian melon or everything like that was
on this exactly the way it was in the
book which I thought was pretty cool
well some of the stuff from the first
part of the book was left out of the
first movies but yeah he dressed it in
the second half yeah because like I said
this inner cuts between they do
flashbacks and stuff flashbacks and
stuff and I was gonna say to that like a
couple of scenes where they actually had
the kid actor and then like it would
morph in
the adult characters because you could
really tell like how they I heard that
they asked like some of the kid actors
who do you think should play you as an
adult and they actually took those
recommendations so I thought that was
pretty cool like it you know what I mean
because they did a really good job it's
like no nobody was unbelievable like
nobody's stuck out as I totally bought
it like I said I forgot there was a
couple of scenes like with I think it
was with Bill and Bev and like they rode
off and then they showed Bev as a grown
up and I was just like oh there she goes
with her kid self and then I was like oh
yeah they're two different so they did
really do a good job with that so the
King makes cameo and and oh yeah
actually actually and he's actually good
in it
a lot of times he's not good he's
actually good enough I actually like I
could see how bit it might piss people
off but I actually liked it yeah I
thought it was okay I thought it was
very funny yeah and there's a small bit
part also I liked the the running joke
throughout the film about the the one
character bill he's played by James
McAvoy and how he's a novelist and how
the endings of his books are always
shitty yeah so there's like so I thought
that was kind of cool because Stephen
King gets that [ __ ] a lot about how his
books are really good but the endings
always suck so I thought it was like
funny that they had that as a running
gag like that was booked worth like
Stephen King gone yeah yeah I know they
say so I thought that was funny that
they incorporated it into the plot but
yeah so as I said I've watched a lot of
other interviews with this but you know
most of them a lot of them seem really
positive a couple of them had like some
issues like oh it's too long or blah
blah blah some other [ __ ] or it wasn't
scary enough or whatever but I really
liked it a lot as I said I'm not gonna
say I liked it better in the first one
because I'd have to watch them both like
back-to-back to make that assessment
because it's been 2 years since I've
seen the first one and I would also
probably have to reread the book again
just to see like what the relationship
was between it but all in all I mean I
enjoyed this movie very much I was I
didn't feel like it was too long I
wasn't bored or anything like that I
thought it was really entertaining um
you know a lot of the humor in it I
really liked that night appreciated that
a lot of the monsters were cool there
was like some creepy scenes and [ __ ]
like that so you know
I thought it was pretty [ __ ] good
what do you think yeah oh you just like
spacing out you guys like bored when I'm
talking I just said everything I had to
say about it okay but yeah seriously go
see it it was really good and you know
make your own judgment see how that goes
[Music]